[Music]
on July 26th 1943 Los Angeles was
blanketed by a thick gas that stung
people's eyes and blocked out the Sun
panicked residents believed their city
had been attacked using chemical warfare
but the cloud wasn't an act of war it
was smog a portmanteau of smoke and fog
the word smog was coined at the
beginning of the 20th century to
describe the thick grey haze that
covered cities such as London Glasgow
and Edinburgh this industrial smog was
known to form when smoke from coal
burning home stoves and factories
combined with moisture in the air but
the small behind the la panic was
different it was yellowish with a
chemical odor since the city didn't burn
much coal its cause would remain a
mystery until a chemist named re Hagen
Schmidt identified two culprits volatile
organic compounds or vocs and nitrogen
oxides VOCs are compounds that easily
become vapors and may contain elements
such as carbon oxygen hydrogen chlorine
and sulfur some are naturally produced
by plants and animals but others come
from man-made sources like Sullivan's
paints glues and petroleum meanwhile the
incomplete combustion of gas in motor
vehicles releases nitrogen oxide that's
what gives this type of smog its
yellowish color VOCs and nitrogen oxide
react with sunlight to produce secondary
pollutants called pans and TRO
phosphoric or ground-level ozone pans
and ozone cause I irritate and damage
lung tissue
both are key ingredients in
photochemical smog which is what had
been plaguing LA so why does smog affect
some cities but not others both
industrial and photochemical smog
combine man-made pollution with local
weather and geography London's high
humidity made it a prime location for
industrial smog photochemical smog is
strongest in
urban areas with calm winds and dry warm
sunny weather the ultraviolet radiation
from sunlight provides the energy
necessary to break down molecules that
contribute to smog formation cities
surrounded by mountains like LA or lying
in a basin like Beijing are also
especially vulnerable to smog since
there's nowhere for it to dissipate
that's also partially due to a
phenomenon known as temperature
inversion where instead of warm air
continuously rising upward a pollution
filled layer of air remains trapped near
the Earth's surface by a slightly warmer
layer above smog isn't just an aesthetic
eyesore both forms of smog irritate the
eyes nose and throat exacerbate
conditions like asthma and emphysema and
increase the risk of respiratory
infections like bronchitis smog can be
especially harmful to young children and
older people an exposure in pregnant
women has been linked to low birth
weight and potential birth defects
secondary pollutants found in
photochemical smog can damage and weaken
crops and decrease yield making them
more susceptible to insects yet for
decades small was seen as the inevitable
price of civilization Londoners had
become accustomed to the notorious
pea-soup fog swirling over their streets
until 1952 when the great smog of London
shut down all transportation in the city
for days and caused more than 4,000
respiratory deaths as a result the Clean
Air Act of 1956 banned burning coal in
certain areas of the city leading to a
massive reduction in smog similarly
regulations on vehicle emissions and gas
content in the u.s. reduced the volatile
compounds in the air and smog levels
along with them
smog remains a major problem around the
world countries like China and Poland
that depend on coal for energy
experience high levels of industrial
smog photochemical smog and airborne
particles from vehicle emissions affect
many rapidly developing cities from
Mexico City and Santiago to New Delhi
enter
governments have tried many methods to
tackle it such as banning cars from
driving for days at a time as more than
half of the world's population crowds
into cities considering a shift to mass
transit and away from fossil fuels may
allow us to breathe easier the author of
the ted-ed lesson you just viewed is a
high school science teacher in Buffalo
New York named Kim fresh off in her
first 30 years as a teacher Kim has
worked face to face with approximately
6,000 students a few years ago Kim who
is still a practicing teacher started
pitching her lesson ideas to Ted Edie
her pitches were solid and were thrilled
to report that this is her fifth video
on our platform in two years mrs.
pressure offs videos have been viewed by
learners over 1.5 million times we'd
love it if you showed Kim some love in
the comments and if you'd like to help
us amplify the impact of more educators
like Kim please consider supporting our
nonprofit mission on patreon.com slash
Ted Edie thanks for watching
[Music]